[Music]
my name is giuseppe I am Italian and I
started dancing ten years ago by
chance for an Italian choreographer
virgilio sieni who wanted to know
some things about blind people
aspects of the movement and from there I
started a journey through
different types of dance but always
remaining  let's say close to that of di
virgilio and then gradually also from this
path after several years there are about
5 years and 6 I have come to know
different other artists and also
companies that
work with disabled people through
international exchanges like the one
that brought us  here in maastricht
for the laboratory and from that moment he
began to work also in other countries, let's say
outside Italy with other
different choreographers
[Music]
the first solo I did with virgilio
competition atlas of white and it was a
study on how colors influence
movement and how to explain
a color with movement and there are
small passages of qu  This performance
in which it was a white room
recreated completely white space and
was flooded with color and through
a particular color the movement
in the scene changed completely
[Music]
to be able to access has made dance
to do  to be an artist in general
and in a professional way to people
who have disabilities in my opinion this is
an important fact that is to be able to
have these people access in
a free way for example or the
elections of schools
where they can enrich or
culturally enrich practically
everything they  he needs it to become
professionals in a field such
as art, dance or for mental
other type of art I wish it were
possible this would be a mission
[Music]